tu es un homme tu as l'air un peu stressé
la seule raison pour laquelle nous avons lancé cette mission
est parce que tu as dit que tu pouvais garantir
un plan B peut-être que tu devrais essayer
ce relax ne t'inquiète pas je suis formé par la CIA
mon esprit aussi  Strong Village Kidman est un
rock CIA Merci Leon
ce n'est pas le moment de faire ce nez Je
voulais juste enlever le bord des ongles
qu'ils ont eu ce n'était peut-être pas une bonne
idée parce que j'ai l'impression que mon pénis
murmure
le fait est que je '  Je te regarde en ce moment
et ta tête a la taille d'une mandarine
et le reste de ton corps a la taille normale
c'est juste que ta tête est minuscule c'est
juste moi
[Musique]